Speaker 1: So we're getting our first sort
of serious signal that this could be a really
ugly midterm election for Democrats, and it
comes from none other than the Georgia Senate
race, where former NFL football player Herschel
Walker, who we've covered quite a bit.
I mean, he's one of the least qualified people
running for Senate right now is leading the
incumbent Democratic Senator Raphael Warnock.
We're going to look at polling, and it would
be funny if it weren't so sad and scary, so
new.
Emerson College poll Georgia Walker versus
Warnock Walker, leading 49 to 45 with six
percent undecided.
Now, of course, there's a three percent margin
of error either way and six percent undecided,
so this could go either way.
But these are not good numbers, and this is
not the only poll that has it this way.
If we look at the real clear politics page
where you could see a number of the recent
polls, you see that Walker is leading by an
average of one point six.
He's +4 in the Emerson poll I just mentioned
Walker is plus one in the recent Quinnipiac
poll.
Walker is plus three in the AJC poll and then
back in August of last year in the Democratic
leaning poll, Raphael Warnock was ahead.
So we don't have that much polling, but none
of it looks particularly good for Raphael
Warnock, and this should genuinely scare us.
This is this is one of the most uninformed
people that is running for prominent office.
Raphael Warnock, for whatever you may like
or dislike about him, particularly as the
incumbent, to see him doing this poorly is
very bad.
Remember that we've talked about recently,
Rafaela?
I'm sorry, Herschel Walker, not Raphael Warnock
said.
If evolution is real, why are there still
apes?
Remember this brilliant analysis
Speaker 2: here that mean, is somebody up
there here to say, let there be light that
Earth started?
And then he had to put someone there or Adam
was there?
Remember, Adam came there, the eve came, so
somebody had to sort it out.
That means it had to be a guy.
Putting up some bomb blew up in his door.
And then I'll tell you something else.
I heard nothing about this because at one
time, Cyrus, a man, came from apes, right?
Did it not?
I didn't go to the site every time I read
or hear that, I think to myself, you just
didn't read the same bible.
I did.
Well, this was interesting, though.
If that is true, why are there still apes?
Think about it, you know, now you're getting
too smart.
No, no, no, no, the thing about this is we
have an evolution that is we've gotten so
intelligent that if that is true, why this
Speaker 1: deal right now?
Of course, we've talked about this so many
times before.
Well, modern apes and modern humans have a
shared ancestor a really long time ago.
And if they're if dogs evolved from wolves,
why are there still wolves here?
I mean, it doesn't make any sense, but this
guy's winning.
This guy winning and this is what we're up
against and the voters hear that and they
go, that's better than Raphael Warnock.
That's a real problem.
Here's another one of Herschel Walker at a
recent Trump rally.
I think this one was about two two weeks ago
saying that he's sick of S.T.A.R..
Whoa, it's crazy.
Speaker 2: S.T.A.R., over this country, people
want to ask me all the time while running,
I'm sick and tired, I'm sick and tired of
them.
Want to teach CPR in school?
Critical race theory.
Can you tell me what that mean?
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, let's start getting
the acronym correct, which is, of course,
CRT.
This is the guy that's winning.
This is the guy that might replace Raphael
Warnock in the Senate.
So it's very difficult.
You know, in general, elections aren't isolated.
And what I mean by that is if there's a bunch
of incumbents, if there's one incumbent knocked
out, there will probably be a bunch of incumbents
knocked out.
But if I think of sort of bellwether representation
of the midterms, if you see the incumbent
Raphael Warnock
Speaker 2: lose
Speaker 1: to a guy who can barely string
together a coherent thought and again, if
he has a brain injury from playing football,
OK, I mean, it's not been announced that he
does.
Maybe it's possible, but it's it's it's dubious
whether the guy even kind of has his head
on straight.
If if Raphael Warnock loses to this guy.
It is really going to be a bad sign for what
the midterms have in store, and it's probably
a bad sign for 2024.
It's probably a bad sign for Joe Biden in
general in his second two years of his presidency.
Never underestimate the stupidity of the electorate.
That's what we learned from Trump in 2016,
when I was part of it, saying the country
wouldn't be so dumb as to vote.
The Republicans wouldn't be so dumb as to
make this guy their dumb nominee, right?
And they were.
And then while the country wouldn't be so
dumb as to make this guy.
Oh, and they did.
This is a red alert emergency.
It could be disastrous for Democrats.
It could be disastrous for the country.
And those polls look terrible